that report makes for tough viewing and
we'll be discussing that more in a
moment but just some breaking news to
bring you now we reported in the last
half an hour that Royal Mail workers
have voted overwhelmingly in favor of
more strike action well now the Royal
College of Nursing has also announced
more industrial action a significant
escalation in terms of the strikes that
they've carried out so far at more than
120 NHS Employers in England will see
more strike action in this dispute
overpay and Staffing and the Royal
College of Nursing has accused the
government of refusing to engage in
negotiations and said it will increase
financial support for his members who
lose wages by taking industrial action
but as I've just said this will be an
escalation of strike action which will
begin on the 1st of March from 6 a.m and
it will run continuously but 48 Hours
the previous strikes that we've seen so
far with nurses took place only during
day shifts for 12 hours at a time but
this next round of industrial action
will see nurses striking
continuously for two days for 48 hours
from 6 a.m on the 1st of March a
significant escalation in strike action
by nurses though